hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
cm.l2-3.4.1 establish and maintain
Baseline configurations and inventories
of organizational systems including
Hardware software firmware and
documentation throughout the respective
system development life cycles
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SB 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already work colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here baby at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so in cmmccontrol
cm.l2-3.4.1 establish and maintain
Baseline configurations and inventories
of organizational systems including
Hardware software firmware and
documentation throughout the respective
system development life cycles here we
find ourselves running into yet more
documentation requirements I know you're
swimming in paper and guess what it's
time to do the backstroke baby because
there's more of it coming your way this
time it's the requirement to have
Baseline documentation okay uh and I
have to tell you it never surprises me
to walk into organizations uh and and we
ask for documentation kind of before we
get there use those kind of crickets we
show up there say hey cool let's see
your network diagram they hand us like
one Visio diagram of a fairly basic sort
of high level topology if we're lucky
most places we don't even get that but
they basically don't have documentation
on their Network and only we've what we
find is that there's really little to no
documentation all on the network so to
me this is really scary stuff because
you know if you have a problem and you
need to bring in a third party to
troubleshoot it or if you have a problem
like you you know something on your
network gets wiped out how are you going
to know how it all went back together
and that's kind of one of the core
fundamental basics of nist is know what
you've got you know to begin with and if
you're you know again a small to
mid-sized it shop or I.T department and
you really haven't you know done your
your sort of your paperwork and your
documentation and you're like what's the
point I'm trying to put out fires and
put out tickets you know here's what
I'll tell you it's so worth it all right
it's one of those things you don't have
to do it terribly often but for one
thing if you're a defense contractor
you're required by law to have that
stuff on paper that way you can
demonstrate to an assessor or someone in
the dod what exactly you have going on
if there's a question about it where if
you're attacked it's really really
important and you're going to look
really silly if something bad happens
and you can't even whip out some basic
Network documentation now there are lots
and lots of cool ways to do it if you're
just needing a really fast way to do it
we have some automated methods along
with some people that will help you with
the risk management piece uh and even
the review of the documentation piece we
also do that that is definitely a
service that we offer uh and again we
can help you every step of the way when
it comes to compliance Network audits uh
documentation things like that I'll get
in a little bit later but for now let's
check out what the assessors are looking
for on this one how to make them happy
so on this one fair warning they're
looking for a bunch of stuff okay
there's like a through F and I think if
my counting is correct I think that's
like six different things they want to
assess you on again this is one of the
bigger controls so
what are they looking for first number
one determine if a baseline
configuration is established in other
words do you even have any documentation
hey free points if you've got it failing
if you don't all right so again we would
probably put down as an answer pretty
simple straightforward hey it's
implemented C organizations Network
documentation on file uh again one of
the first things we do whenever we step
in any client that we're helping you a
compliant is we run some pretty awesome
software that essentially takes care of
every bit of this and creates some
amazing amazing Network documentation
performs internal and external network
audits uh and penetration tests and
things like that so again it's it's it's
really for us it's like square one we
can't even understand your network until
we do that all right assessment Point
number two determine if the Baseline
configuration includes Hardware software
firmware and documentation again this is
on you right so it's assuming that
you've got that but you have to go to
that level right Hardware software yes
they want a list of every piece of
software you're running why because if
you've got a baseline you've got some
other weird software you can refer back
to the Baseline and well you'll know
that it was always there or that it
wasn't so either way it's still pretty
important and again the answer itself is
the same it's implemented see the
organization's Network documentation
that's on file have it available for
your assessor have it available for your
boss only if you want to keep your job
right all right Point number three
determine if the Baseline configuration
is maintained ah now we get a little bit
more complicated right has it been
reviewed has it been updated throughout
the system development life cycle okay
so now what does that mean that means
you got to have a a baseline right you
gotta have some point where you begin
but then you got to have more iterations
of it okay you've got to show over time
that you're doing the work all right and
you're updating it you've got new
versions of it okay this is all very
important we love using ticketing
systems to keep track of everything that
we do and you know we'll put this year's
as an attachment to a service ticket
it's a great way to keep track of it if
I was to answer this one I would say
implemented you know see organizations
Network documentation on file updated in
real time daily through and again just
sort of an example we have a remote
monitoring and management system that
can actually take attachments uh it
includes a ticketing system and so again
we actually say CR ticketing system uh
for annual service tickets on network
documentation updating again lots of
lots of flexibility in what the answer
could be but the idea really is is that
you've got history on it
next determine if a system inventory is
established right do we have an
inventory so again does your
documentation actually include a total
inventory so somebody can go down the
inventory list and see exactly what you
have in there from a hardware software
firmware perspective Etc again we'll
just have an easy answer to it on paper
which is Implement see the organizations
that were documentation on file
obviously be prepared to show that
determine if the system inventory
includes Hardware software firmware and
documentation Again by now you're just
kind of repeating yourself I don't know
why they have this extra assessment
point in here but I did write this thing
and I'm sure there's a really good
reason to really get super granular on
what that documentation's got to have in
it again uh same answer really is see
the organizations Network documentation
on file and then you're gonna you're
gonna basically break out all your
reports for that Assessor final one
number six determine if the inventory is
maintained that is reviewed and updated
throughout the system development life
cycle okay again is someone looking at
this stuff okay can you point to a
service ticket where you went back and
said hey Freddy and tech support on tier
one go look at the network diagram if
you want to figure out how that works
okay hopefully that's a yes uh so again
Implement see organizations Network
documentation on file again guys they're
not looking for brain surgery here
um you just got to have some ability to
basically say hey look here it is it's
in our ticketing system we can refer
back to it when needed all right awesome
and again that should cover everything
for this control but if you got 109 more
to go no worries because in on-call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this dfars nist itar
and cmfc compliant stuff dropped into
their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you
and if you're looking for more help
getting compliant our compliance experts
are always on call for you you can visit
cmmccompliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now like literally right now if
you go there you can self-schedule time
one of our certified compliance experts
and I bet they're available right now
yeah pretty much all the time
if you love the content we're putting
out here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash that subscribe button to
get the latest compliance content as
soon as our compliance there is roll it
out until the next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below to let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance and I'll see you on the
next one
foreign
[Music]